[Musik]
es ist das plötzliche ende einer wie es
schien unendlichen geschichte vor zwei
tagen tritt sepp blatter überraschend
vor die medien und gibt seinen rücktritt
als fifa-präsident bekannt er habe den
rückhalt bei verbänden und spielern
verloren
[Musik]
ich habe mich deshalb entschieden
zurückzutreten weil ich überzeugt bin
dass dies das beste ist für die
organisation
die heutige fifa ist z blatt das werk im
guten wie im schlechten noch wird über
die wahren hintergründe dieses
unerwarteten abgang spekuliert
doch die turbulenzen der letzten tage
vermochten offenbar auch den
widerstandsfähigen sap zu erschüttern
und mit ihm wankt ebenso die fifa dieser
mächtigste stolzeste und reichste
sportverband ein blick zurück im leben
der schillernden präsidenten zeigt wie
es so weit kommen konnte
sepp blatter 79 jahre alt 40 jahre
prägte er das system fifa das eben so
ein system blatter ist zuerst als
generalsekretär die letzten 17 jahre als
präsident dafür wird er verehrt dafür
wird der gast dort als fußball welt ist
tief gespalten und doch schien bislang
nichts den herrscher des weltfußballs
stoppen zu können
[Musik]
am letzten freitag sind sie aus der
ganzen welt angereist stundenlanges
ausharren vor den zürcher hallenstadion
nur um antwort auf eine frage zu
bekommen wird er es ein weiteres mal
schaffen werden die 209 delegierten den
betagten mann ein fünftes mal zum fifa
präsidenten wählen auch nach all den
dramatischen vorkommnissen der letzten
tage
am hintereingang des hallenstadions
bereitet sich ein jubelchor auf seinen
auftritt vor
angeblich volkstümlicher beitrag als
kontrast zum messer wetzen im
hauptprogramm dieses 65 fifa kongresses
vom letzten freitag
die organisatoren haben sich alle mühe
gegeben mit einem bekömmlichen
rahmenprogramm die schärfe die
auseinandersetzungen etwas zu dämpfen
auf der vorderseite hingegen wo kameras
und mikrofone seit stunden schon fiebrig
auf ihren einsatz warten nutzen
palästina freunde die gunst der stunde
und marschieren auf den haupteingang los
sie fordern dass israel aus der fifa
ausgeschlossen wird
am gelassensten zeigen sich in diesen
turbulenzen noch die zürcher polizisten
die allein mit gutem zureden und dem
heer zeigen ihres arsenals einen sturm
auf den fifa kongress abwenden eben noch
haben sie das hallenstadion über mittag
räumen müssen eine bombendrohung eine
lehre wie sich herausgestellt hat doch
das einzige was hier wirklich
interessiert ist die frage blatter ja
oder nein ein delegierter aus dem
afrikanischen sambia hält unverbrüchlich
zum schweizer fifa präsidenten
die afrikaner werden zu 100 prozent für
blatter stimmen 100 prozent da bin ich
absolut sicher der mann hat viel für uns
getan man kann in jedem land sehen was
die fifa für uns geleistet hat
[Musik]
andrew jennings sieht das anders der
schottische journalist hat mit seinen
recherchen die jüngsten ermittlungen der
us justiz mit in gang gebracht
ist er zufrieden
der strähnig sepp blatter in
handschellen sehe werde ich richtig
glücklich sein
zwei tage zuvor in zürcher luxushotel
ballack morgens nach 6 uhr holen
polizisten in zivil sechs fifa top leute
aus ihren betten und verhaften sie
aufgrund eines auslieferungsbegehrens
der amerikanischen justiz
[Musik]
verdächtigt werde
im laufe des tages wird noch ein siebter
fifa man in zürich verhaftet
die spektakuläre aktion findet in
anwesenheit der weltmedien start diese
sind wegen des fifa kongresses sind die
schweiz gereist am fifa-hauptsitz am
zürichberg versuchte offenbar
überrumpelte fifa kommunikationsdirektor
walter de gregorio antworten auf die
vielen fragen der journalisten zu finden
und die vordringlichste frage lautet wo
ist sepp blatter
fifa-präsident und auch der
generalsekretär sind nicht beschuldigte
sie sind nicht involviert in diesem
verfahren mittlerweile scheint das nicht
mehr zu gelten gegen beide ermittelt
laut new york times das fbi
kommunikationsdirektor der gregorio
versuchte zu diesem zeitpunkt noch das
beste aus der situation zu machen
das begrüßen
ein schwieriger moment in den usa
erläutert justizministerin loretta lynch
der war die hintergründe des verfahrens
da sind nicht nur die sieben
inhaftierten in der schweiz insgesamt
laufen gegen 14 fifa leute
ermittlungsverfahren korruption im ganz
großen stil
sie taten es immer wieder für jahr
turnier für turnier
und die resolute justizministerin gibt
klar zu verstehen man sei erst um
beginnende anstrengungen und werde noch
sehr tief karben
zu den verhafteten zelt jeffrey web von
den cayman islands bislang ein
saubermann und ziehsohn von fifa
präsident blatter
eine andere zentrale figur des
korruptionsskandals ist jack warner
ebenfalls aus der karibik ein alter
freund blatters jahre lang sein
stimmenbeschaffer dafür durfte er mit
geschenkten fifa fernsehrechten anderen
unabhängig von den amerikanern ermittelt
auch die schweizer bundesanwaltschaft
denn im jahre 2010 sollen ebenfalls
illegal gelder geflossen sein
bei der vergabe der weltmeisterschaften
nach katar und russland
der vormalige blatter freund michel
platini präsident des europäischen
fußball verbandes uefa wird das messer
gegen seinen einstigen förderer
er spricht von einem boykott des
kongresses er ruft dazu auf blatter
abzuwählen ein herrlich lauter streit
von den berichterstattern gerne
kolportiert
doch es sollte beim wirkungslosen getöse
bleiben
einen tag später muss der platter zur
eröffnung des 65 fifa kongresses vor die
öffentlichkeit treten er tut was er in
solchen fällen stets tut er distanziert
sich von seinen einstigen getreuen
wie
wir oder ich wir können nicht jeden die
ganze zeit überwachen
wenn leute unerlaubtes tun dann werden
sie auch versuchen dies zu vertuschen
was die fifa anbelangt gehört jens
weinreich zu den best informierten
journalisten er sieht sepp blatter im
zentrum eines korrumpierten fifa systems
natürlich ist es ein system es gibt da
keine einzeltäter blatter ist
bestandteil dieses systems jack warner
hat ihm anderthalb jahrzehnte die
stimmen garantiert der karibik jeffrey
web ist sein mannsein wahlhelfer 2002
den er aufgebaut hat angeblich als sein
nachfolger aber das entscheidende ist
blatter hat dieses weltumspannende
korruptionssystem gibst du mir geb ich
dir stimmen ich lass dich gewähren ich
lass dich geschäfte machen mit aufgebaut
und verfeinert über 40 jahre über 40
jahre in der fifa
ob das so ist die ermittlungen in den
usa werden es womöglich zeigen heute
aber ist freitag der tag der wahl und es
sind solche tage an denen sepp blatter
zu großer form aufläuft mit einem
weinerlichen pathos das viele hier im
saal zu erwärmen vermag
ganz einfach alles was ich möchte ist
bei euch zu bleiben ich möchte gerne mit
euch weiter fahren
sein farbloser widersacher der
jordanische prinz ali bin al hussein hat
gegen diesen trickreichen man keine
chance
nach quälend langen wahlprozedere heißt
es 133 stimmen für blatter 73 für den
prinzen der auf einen zweiten wahlgang
verzichtet
sepp blatter hat seine fünfte wahl als
fifa-präsident geschafft und dies unter
sehr schwierigen aktuellen umständen was
ist das für ein mann ein blick zurück in
der geschichte dieses virtuosen macht
technikers
sepp blatter ist im oberwallis in visp
aufgewachsen
morgen im halben jahr scharfe immer mit
einem blauen
und
wirtschaft bis zum 20.12
die schneiden kurz mit
dem film
40 jahre 40 jahren
wir schaffen seiner enkeltochter selena
zeigt blatter wo er herkommt aus
bescheidenen verhältnissen
streng katholisch aufgewachsen mit zwei
brüdern und einer schwester
der vater arbeitete in einer
chemiefabrik in
[Musik]
zwei kinder kochen
und der großbagger jeder morgen prüfend
untergang als junger mann maskiert und
hier sind die övp wachse die ganz
familie bleibt aber natürlich willkommen
es
abklären wirtschaft wenn ich mal die
erste woche die hacker eine symbolische
botschaft der wähler
mit dem feri ag der frühere austria wird
das hätte er nichts ich gehe ich mit der
mieterin agatha geschafft für österreich
ein friedhof durch derzeit dort steht er
immer und das arbeiten der schaffende
aber die musik nicht zu arbeiten du
musst auch etwas schaffen etwas
erschaffen
und so ist der kleine selbst ausgezogen
aus dem oberwallis und schließlich in
der großen welt der ganz wichtigen leute
angekommen
ich wurde als weil ich mit meinem bruder
zusammen hatten sie denn wir sind nur
elf monate auseinander sind noch die
gleichen schule gegangen gleiche klasse
und
ich wurde immer noch sehr kleine blatter
weil der andere etwas größer war wurde
jetzt der kleine blätter dargestellt
richtig
und das hat mir dann 360 initiativ
gegeben aber nicht der kleine der
trainer zu sein
[Musik]
es war im jahre 1998 in paris nach 17
jahren als generalsekretär wollte sehr
platter nun den ganz großen schritt an
die spitze machen und präsident der fifa
werden nachfolger des eisernen
alleinherrschers havelange aus brasilien
doch er stand ihm im wege der schwede
lennart johansson von der mächtigen
wafer der wahlkampf war dramatisch und
schmutzig johansson ließ keinen zweifel
offen dass er blatter nicht mochte wer
gewinnt sie oder sepp blatter
er steht für kontinuität
das heißt für ein diktatorisches
verhalten und die ausschaltung
demokratischer regeln
ist er für sie ein diktator
doch sepp blatter schaffte es und wurde
zum fifa-präsidenten gewählt zur
mächtigsten sportfunktionär der welt
der triumph war großartig
blatter war am ziel seiner träume
[Musik]
und vor den kameras taten die zwei
erbitterte feinde so als wäre alles
vergessen als wären sie nun freunde
geworden ein trugbild
denn der konflikt war nicht vorbei
kritische zeitungen beschuldigten
blatter die präsidentschaft erkauft zu
haben in diesem pariser hotel soll er in
der nacht vor der wahl an afrikanische
fifa-delegierte umschläge mit tausenden
von dollar verteilt und so die stimmen
gekauft haben
als blatter von einem reporter des
schweizer fernsehens danach gefragt
wurde wirkte er nicht gerade überzeugend
in der hotelbar feierten die
afrikanischen wahlkampfhelfer den sieg
von sepp blatter
wir reisen viel herum wir gingen auch
südafrika nach ghana kenia
wir hatten ein wunderbares essen dort
mit unseren freunden in einem
wunderschönen restaurant
es ist karneval es war fantastisch wie
assen alligatoren krokodile das gab uns
kraft für den kampf um herrn blatter
nach vorne zu treiben
es war fantastisch
und wer hat die platte kampagne bezahlen
[Musik]
meine reisen die flüge die spesen das
zahlte alles hell hammam aus katar das
ist ein fifa exekutivmitglied
ich reichte ihnen verschiedene länder
ich kann ihnen nicht sagen in welche
weil sie nicht genannt werden wollen
reisen speis und trank ein wahlkampf
nach afrikanischer art bezahlt von einem
arabischen freund doch floss da nicht
auch bares
doch dann tauchten neue vorwürfe auf
welche auf die wahl blatter sein
schiefes licht warfen hassan ali der
fifa delegierte des somalischen
fußballverbandes schilderte mit welchen
versprechungen er für die wahl blatters
geködert worden war
wurden ihnen irgendwelche versprechungen
gemacht wenn sie für blatter stimmen
würden
wie lautet denn diese versprechungen man
versprach uns gilt
er versprach dass bin hammam und
was offerierte er geld flugtickets oder
sonst
man hat uns so viel angeboten
[Musik]
sie gaben uns flugtickets
sie verschaffen uns visa
[Musik]
sie gaben uns taschengeld
doch das wichtigste war sie versprachen
uns gute jobs bei der fifa
sehr guten
prestigeträchtigen positionen
und dafür mussten sie für blatter stehen
mohamed bin hammam
fifa-exekutivmitglied und reicher
blatter freund wollte damals zu diesen
vorwürfen nicht sagen aber es fiel auf
in afrika und arabien bar bin hammam aus
katar stets an blatter seite
bin hamann war
fifa-exekutivmitglied und sehr reich
doch vor allem war er ein treuer
mitstreiter blatters sein wichtigster
stimmenbeschaffer
blatter ist unschlagbar keiner kann mit
ihm konkurrieren
das musste bin hammam später am eigenen
leib erfahren denn 2011 wollte bin
hammam mit den techniken des schmiedens
und schieben es längst vertraut blatter
vom präsidentenstuhl verdrängen doch
nachdem gegen den katarer bestechungs
vorwürfe laut geworden waren zog er sich
von der wahl zurück und platter war
wieder gewählt zum vierten mal und zum
letzten mal wir damals versprach
[Musik]
guido tognoni ein vertrauter bin hammams
war über zehn jahre lang ein fifa
kadermann zweimal von blatter geholt
zwei mal bei diesem in ungnade gefallen
1998 war toni im wahlkampfteam des
schweden johansson und dabei stellte er
einige ungereimtheiten fest
ich weiß dass da einiges passiert ist
das ist jetzt zwölf jahre her die stadt
einiges passiert sind unschöne sachen
geld geflossen ja aber
mehr weiß jetzt dass er
sieht da wurde einwohner hat mittel zu
verfügen das ist das ist unbestritten
dazwischen zieht oder das ist
unbestritten habe ich glaube die leute
wo damals verloren er setzt sofort die
griff sofort die wahl anfechten das ist
nicht passiert und ich glaube ich mieter
zieht läuft das wasser und ufer jährige
[Musik]
der charmante sap der knallharte blatter
einmal volkstümlicher oberwalliser dann
einen drückt der staatsmann durchaus
umgänglich doch auch sehr sehr eitel
heute ein freund morgen einfand
klasse stand sie immer wenn du etwas
erreicht ist es ein sieg page
impressions
das sind neun gesichter wie viele haben
sie joseph blatter
ich habe nur eins ein gesicht bei
herford gewann fest berichtet glaubte
schon sehr schlauer mensch ein sehr
ehrgeiziger mensch unglaublich
ambitionen die ambition eine indien dass
es bis in das höchste amt rät menschen
trickreichen mensch das muss man
wahrscheinlich zum der lga erreichen er
rät auch verschiedene gesichter auch
sehr
freundschaftlich
charmant kollegial lebenswürdig sie er
hat aber handcreme auch israels sie
beruft sich bedacht rein machtpolitisch
urteilen und ohne jegliche
sentimentalität den pussy
vorgenommen
[Musik]
blatter auf besuch in der walliser
heimat wo seine tochter corinne und
enkelin selena wohne
es ist fasnachtszeit und dem restaurant
des schwiegersohns trifft platter
freunde aus alten tagen
blatter ist eben erst von einem besuch
aus südafrika zurück
für die einheimischen ist der
fifa-präsident einer von ihnen einfach
[Gelächter]
es gibt kein protokoll keine
verpflichtungen und platter freund einer
alten tradition die ihnen walliser
weizen noch hochgehalten wird
es werde von 32 jährige zusammen hotel
sie zu hause sind wir zusammen
[Gelächter]
in seinen jungen jahren war blatter
aktiver fußballer er kickte für den fc
visp und beim fc sie das bis in die
dritthöchste spielklasse der schweiz
schaffte er es über seine
fußballerischen qualitäten gehen am
tisch jedoch die meinungen auseinander
[Gelächter]
ich freue mich nach lachsen das wesen
[Musik]
auf dem fußballplatz zeigt enkelin
selena dem großvater ihr klassenzimmer
hier drückte auch schon blatter die
schulbank die gemeinde hatte schulhaus
mittlerweile auf seinen namen getauft
und
morgen halbe achte hätte mir so hier sie
stellt adata und machen 73 und lädt den
prüfen kirche und media sind links nach
rechts
sepp blatter ist neben tennisspieler
roger federer wohl der bekannteste
schweizer weltweit und wo er auch
hinkommt wird er wie ein staatsoberhaupt
empfangen
[Musik]
der status eines staatspräsidenten
dem kann man sich nicht einfach so
erreichen dass geht zusammen mit der
entwicklung des fußballs mit dem
stellenwert des fußballs wenn man in
unserer gesellschaft sieht dass der
fußball heute
direkt oder indirekt eine milliarde
menschen berührt dann hat der fußball
dann auch
einen politischen faktor und in diesem
politischen faktor bewegt sich natürlich
der chef des fußballs dreimal hatte sepp
blatter mit dem heiraten versucht und
drei mal hatte es nicht gehalten die
einzige ehe die hält die szene mit dem
fußball
365 tage im jahr zu boden und in der
luft
sepp blatter ist ein getriebener doch
was eigentlich treibt ihn an
was mich nur abtrieb
mini überzeugt dass das was ich mache
praktisch und dass es noch nicht fertig
ist was ist typisches geld oder
schlussapplaus sieht man verliert gelte
es nicht bereits mit dem geld nicht
absprechen aber geld ist nicht sein
antrieb es ist macht und es ist der
applaus eher ich sehr offene art
liebesbedürftig er braucht die tägliche
under keine gebraucht der tägliche
applaus und maxi das im bilde rené
rudorisch wenn er auf blöd wenn er
verliert auf sich gerichtet und wenn der
applaus nicht vor fremden orten und
ritter sieht dass dies für ihn wenn es
doping und das ist was er eigentlich
sucht spieler von macht und anna klinik
gemacht das ist ihm sehr wichtig
gleiches ungarisches bekannteste platte
verdient ich bin überrascht dass ich
immer das risiko ist groß macht
zumindest mit der folge dass europa zwei
millionen frauen gravierend dass sie
zwischenzeitlich durch lima pvr briefe
aktivieren sondern ein verein worden
ihre idee die ent und warum das wird
eine größte präsident verdient der
präsident für die endnutzer präsident
wird kompensiert für die arbeit war der
magdeburger die den pensionskassen
und nimmt man die pensionsgrenze jetzt
drehte nach schweizerischem der spitze
die schweiz aber soziale not das ist
behauptet wurde eine publikation ist für
die ehre der regel über vier millionen
pro jahr vier millionen dollar 6
millionen schweizer franken um was sagen
sie zu dem hier das sind das sind zahlen
war war ist ein kosmos romand und die
wird immer da wenn konkrete frag jetzt
und dadurch die tv beantwortet ist und
zwei millionen besser ist als richtige
schätze kräftiger als geht das
spezifische zahler und die zahler war da
ist wenn der mal die pranke und die
frage schon gar nicht die kleine die
konkrete frage viel bzw pro jahr gebe da
die antwort
finanzkommission hat das
exekutiv-komitee dass das opera
im jahre 2002 brach innerhalb des
weltfußballverbandes der nächste
machtkampf
ausgerechnet im jahr das ich platte der
wiederwahl stellen musste und die
attacke stammte ausgerechnet von
blatters generalsekretär michel zen
ruffinen dem anderen walliser in der
fifa
die vorwürfe von zen ruffinen waren
beeindruckend
blatter führt die fifa wie ein diktator
blatter verletze die fifa-statuten vater
missbrauche finanzielle hilfsprogramme
um seine eigene macht voran zu treiben
blatter betreibe eine falsche
buchführung blatter vergebe an freunde
und verwandte aufträge
blatter sei korrupt
bis unkorrekten der fall aufhören
technisch absolut das meldebehörde
sportlich blatter musste sich einmal
mehr verteidigen diesmal gegen seinen
eigenen saison es kommt von einem mann
den ich liebe mein sohn seit 14 jahren
in der fifa hoch geschätzt und nicht zu
sagen hochgezogen habe dann tut es
irgendwie weh
einige fifa exekutivmitglieder darunter
lennart johansson und david will gingen
mit seinen ruf ins klageschrift zur
bezirksanwaltschaft in zürich es war
eine besondere situation als zehn
trophäen und das papier vorliegt viele
von uns war schockiert
in zürich ermittelte die justiz doch für
eine anklage reichte es offenbar nicht
es war ja ein struggle for power also es
geht ja nur noch um die macht und es
wurden alle hebel in bewegung setzt da
würde ich betrachte jetzt also doch als
eine anmaßung und eine frechheit wenn
man den eigenen fifa-präsidenten
einklagt
aber blatter steckte damals in einer
sehr ungemütlichen lage denn die
wiederwahl stand an und seine gegner
hatten sich formiert am fifa-kongress
von 2002 in salt kann es zur großen
abrechnung
nochmals klagte generalsekretär 10 rufen
den präsidenten an zahlungen aus der
fifa- kasse gemacht zu haben die gemäss
schweizer gesetz illegal gewesen seien
[Musik]
lotta konterte ihn nebulös prophetischer
weise
es ist wie es ist irgendwann mal wird
die wahrheit sicher ans licht komme dann
werden wir weitersehen
dann die wahl
number of thoughts vor mister joseph
blatter
und platter feind zen ruffinen durfte
den namen des siegers mitteilen joseph
blatter nach monatelangen kleinkrieg
innerhalb der fifa trieb der triumph
blatter tränen in die augen
[Applaus]
blatters herausforderer der afrikaner
issa hayatou gab sich geschlagen
monatelang wurde ich von einer gewissen
fehlgeleiteten presse als schlechter
mensch dargestellt
doch ihr habt mich gewählt
und die alle könnte auch nicht schlecht
sein
also sind wir alle gut
steht auf und gibt euch die hände tut es
für den fußball
das spiel heißt fußball und der sieger
stets sepp blatter wie schafft er das
gegen all die widerstände gegen diese
geballte kritik
und obama darüber nachdenkt dominiak
rede gestellt platter ist der einzige
mensch auf der welt im weltfußball und
rainer führers tag im jahr zieht der
machterhalt nauck
in ulrichen im goms lebten blatt aus
vorfahren dieses dorf hat blatter nicht
ein schulhaus sondern einen fußballplatz
gewidmet einmal im jahr immer im sommer
rezept blatter die prominenz der
internationalen fußballszene auf dem
spielplatz seiner heimatgemeinde ein
hier gibt es blatter und andere stars
hautnah zum anfassen
damals treu an blatter seite zwei andere
mächtige des europäischen fußballs franz
beckenbauer und uefa-präsident michel
platini der mittlerweile zum feind
geworden ist
hier in den walliser bergen ziehen die
mächtigen des fußballs auch schon mal
die fäden für weltweit bedeutende
entscheidungen
in der alpinen kulisse läuft beziehungs
künstler blatter zu hochform auf
wenn die würzigen duft des oberwallis
oder in den kongress hellen
irgendwelcher luxushotels sepp blatter
bleibt jahrzehntelang stets dieser
meisterliche strippenzieher
geben und nehmen alles richtig dosiert
und wichtig stets am ball bleibt
unermüdlich immer den spielverlauf
selbst bestimmen
seit jahren schon beobachtet der
deutsche journalist jens weinreich die
nebulösen vorgänge im weltfussball
verband blattes virtuose technik der
macht schildert er so
blatter hat dieses system des gebens und
nehmens in der fifa mit geprägt von
anfang an mit aufgebaut ausgebaut
erweitert er ist ja insgesamt schon 35
jahre in der fifa maßgeblich tätig
direktor generalsekretär und präsident
er ich würde mal sagen er weiß fast
alles vielleicht würde sogar einer
stillen stunde sagen er weiß alles was
ist die wichtigste fähigkeit umsichtige
frauen und diese späteren jetzt haut
oder fähigkeit ufer schweizer mehrere
sprachen
gegenüber jeder mensch wohin bewegen
begegnet kann also zum ausdruck bringen
dass ihm der mensch unglaublich wichtig
ist das ist phänomenal irdische pcx
künstler
ergeben die drucktechnologien gewartet
ohne jeden druck ist für die macher
neue jahr 2004 das ja der regierung
gegen blatter 2002 liegt noch nicht weit
zurück und zum fifa neujahrsempfang
heißt auch der große widersacher aus
schweden lennart johansson an die
situation ist gespannt einerseits hat
blatter die chance generös zu sein
andererseits weiß niemand ob johansson
platte öffentlich bloßstellt
das kann man sehen und ich bin sehr froh
darüber
[Musik]
damen und herren freunde des fußballs
vertreter der medien was immer es
alle die in der republik dem publikum
insbesondere möchte
johansson begrüßen und durch die
winternacht wenn sie gleich zwei leute
an die usa ausrichten
[Applaus]
herr präsident ich nehme die gelegenheit
wahr für eine kurze rede
ich bitte euch eine für uns sehr
wichtige sache zu respektieren ich stehe
hier neben einem guten freund
die ereignisse der letzten jahre sind
vergessen vor allem von beiden
beim fußball geht es um gewinnen oder
verlieren und ich habe gelernt dass man
wissen muss wenn man verloren an
das waren nicht nur schöne worte das war
den titel worte ich danke dir lieber
lehnert
ich nehme nicht nur die beute auf auch
deine freundschaft und zusammen werden
wir die probleme meistern die effektiv
im internationalen fussball existieren
und ohne die uefa kann die fifa nicht
arbeiten auf alle fälle nicht
erfolgreich und sein handwerk zum
präsidenten möchte ich offiziell ist und
plateau entwaffnet seinen leuten
widersacher vor laufenden kameras der
fallend von gestern wird zum freund vom
heute gemacht wirtschaft der wechselnd
fast täglich aber es sind aber keine
freundschaft sondern sind reine bezirks
gelegt wo kurzfristig funktionieren es
sind bezirke zur machterhaltung als sie
mithilfe verschafften der selbst nicht
viel eingefunden bruch daran seine
position aber es sind koalition aber
ständig wechseln wo man darf nie
vergessen dass sind mentalitäten aus
afrika aus europa und südamerika
das sind klinisch erster linie mich oder
ich linie blick oder nachließ lacher
oder ganz klinische oder sehr wichtige
rolle spielen und wo war oder nur mit
dem seeplatz er in kontakt kommen
wiederum kühl geben siegen die sehr
wichtig
reise nach afrika wo blatters
verlässliche freunde wohnen ohne afrika
gebe es wohl keinen fifa-präsidenten
blatter
bereits bei seiner ersten
präsidentenwahl damals im jahre 1998
haben die afrikaner geholfen den
schweizer auf den schild zu heben
der journalist jens weinreich erinnert
sich an blatters wahl im jahre 1998 und
daran wie dieser die afrikaner in eine
wohl gewogene stimmung versetzt hat
ich habe immer war damals erlebt und
zwar vor der wahl und zwar mit den
kollegen zusammen standen werden der tür
beim mini kongress des afrikanischen
verbandes caf und er hat wie es immer
gemacht hat die afrikaner quasi ich sage
wirklich aufgehetzt gegen die europäer
er kommt dann nämlich immer mit dieser
mit dieser nummer die europäer wollen
und was wegnehmen die europäer denken
noch wie alte kolonialmächte ich spreche
da hat er die liebe zu afrika gar nicht
ab ich glaube sogar dass das da sowas
ist wie also extreme sympathie sagen wir
mal wenn man genau hinguckt dann sieht
man dass seine karriere untrennbar mit
afrika verbundenes
geben und nehmen blatter verdammte die
wahl den afrikanern mit zwei versprechen
die bm und gelder für die entwicklung
des fußballs
und es gibt viel zu verteilen bei der
fifa in mali eröffnet der sepp blatter
2002 das neue hauptquartier des fußball
verbandes
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aus einem entwicklungsfonds dem projekt
coal leistet die fifa jährlich große
beträge für den bau von
infrastruktureinrichtungen wie dieses
verwaltungsgebäude letztes jahr
unterstützte der weltfußballverband
entwicklungsprojekte mit über einer
halben milliarde dollar
und so hatte der magnetische
fußballpräsident nun ein büro das so
groß war wie jenes des
ministerpräsidenten neue büromöbel viele
große räume mit finanziert von den fifa-
entwicklungshelfern
das entwicklungsprojekt ist blatters
baby seit er fifa-präsident ist nahm der
geldfluss aus zürich markant zu
die leeren büros des sportrechtehändler
cell in zug im jahre 2001 ging asl
damals der wichtigste geschäftspartner
der fifa in konkurs
buchprüfer suchten nach verschwundenen
millionen und damit nahm hier in zug
eine affäre ihren anfang die sich zum
größten schmiergeldskandal in der
geschichte des sports aus walten sollte
die untersuchungsbehörden begannen zu
ermitteln denn die fifa selbst hatte
gegen ihren einstigen partner in diesem
milliardengeschäft wegen betrugs geklagt
doch was die justiz in den büchern der
asl fand war gar nicht im interesse der
fifa die beschlagnahmten unterlagen
enthüllten ein gigantisches
korruptionssystem der deutsche
journalist walter billinghausen
entdeckte die schwarze kasse der asl in
liechtenstein eine millionenschwere
stiftung alleine dem zweck dienen
sportfunktionäre zu schmieren um an tv
rechte zu gelangen will man sich
vorstellt dass in der fifa exekutive
ganze 24 leute sitzen die darüber
entscheiden wo die nächsten fußball
weltmeisterschaften stattfinden kann es
ja nicht schaden wenn man da ein paar
millionen in reservate um gegebenenfalls
die ein oder andere stimme zu kaufen
doch welche fifa leute standen auf der
schmiergeld liste an einer turbulenten
pressekonferenz rund um den asl konkurs
verneinte blatter selbst teil dieses
schmiergeld systems zu sein was meinen
sie wie ich da stehe
mit meinen 1300 dienstagen sie wissen
nicht was ein schweizer offiziere im
range eines regiments kommandanten als
verantwortung trägt und ich komme dann
raus als sein als ein betrüger nein
so nicht nicht wie ich nicht ich sicher
nicht drei jahre nachdem die fifa
anzeige gegen die asl erhoben hatte ließ
er blatter den zucker
untersuchungsrichter wissen man sei
nicht mehr interessiert an einer
weiterverfolgung des falles
die fifa begründete am 29 juni 2004 hier
das interesse an einer weiteren
strafverfolgung
ließ der untersuchungsrichter die medien
wissen doch die ermittlungen waren nicht
mehr zu stoppen im jahre 2007 enthüllte
die anklage dann in welch enorme ausmaße
hier schmiergelder geflossen waren
seitenweise waren beträge aufgelistet
welche die asl an funktionäre von
sportverbänden bezahlt hatte allein in
den drei jahren vor dem konkurs waren
bestechungsgelder in höhe von 138
millionen franken geflossen
so überrascht
dass er vor betroffen im selben jahr
nicht überrascht dass andere
sportverbände betroffen worden sind und
ein historischer kurpark der phase wo
der korruption foto großflächiger
korruption im weltsport latinas machte
genau einem sport die schmiergelder
wurden in der regel von asl top manager
jean marie weber in bar und ohne
quittung überbracht weber bezeichnete
die verdeckten zahlungen als provisionen
honorar welche parallel zum kauf oder
verkauf von rechten bezahlt worden seien
und die klageschrift zeigt dass auch
fifa-funktionäre geschmiert worden sind
namentlich aufgelistet ist nicolás leoz
damaliges fifa exekutivmitglied aus
paraguay
und hinter der schmiergeld adresse one
ford
investments.de
damaliges brasilianisches
fifa-exekutivmitglied jetzt im visier
der dortigen justiz
sowohl eos wie auch teheran nachweislich
korrupt gingen noch jahrelang als
ehrenmänner am fifa-hauptsitz ein und
aus leos wird heute von interpol gesucht
juristisch konnten die bestochenen fifa
leute nicht belangt werden weil das
schmieren von sportfunktionären damals
in der schweiz nicht verboten war
doch für ein milliardenunternehmen
welches fairplay auf seine fahnen
geschrieben hat ist dieser befund eine
moralische bankrotterklärung
was wir benötigen das fußbad schaffte
schließlich zu machen ich glaube müsst
ihr sehr sehr viel verändert und jetzt
könnt ihr ziel ich hoffe dass man so
viel verändert das ist eigentlich eine
bilanz ziemlich trostlose bilanz aber im
fussball tummeln sich nicht nur im
fußball auch immer andere sport und sich
so viel über den sport als vehikel
benützen zum mehr oder weniger
geld das man eigentlich der ganze sport
großreinigung unterziehen und das ist
heutzutage nicht mehr möglich aber es
ist ein witz einer fifa und uefa und des
ioc und dem vereinsrecht stellen die der
schweizer zu dass die als verein gemäss
zkb 16 konstruiert wird das ihren riesen
witz was bräuchte es denn um die fifa
etwas ehrlicher zu machen es bräuchte
ein erdbeben es bräuchte ein so nah wie
es müsste das ganze system fifa auf ein
neues fundament gestellt werden es
bräuchte vor allen dingen transparenz
daraus folgernd dann 24
exekutivmitglieder einen neuen
präsidenten einen neuen generalsekretär
der hat auch seine geschichte und es
bräuchte vor allen dingen kontrolle von
außen von unabhängigen institutionen so
ist die überhaupt gibt
dagegen hat sich sehr platte allerdings
jahre lang gesperrt und wenn wir
probleme haben in der familie dann lösen
wir durch die probleme in der familie
und gehen nicht zu einer fremden familie
in diesem sinne alles was im fußball
passiert und alle schwierigkeiten im
fußball sind sollen innerhalb der
fußballerischen gerichtsbarkeit oder
rechtsprechung gemacht werden und nicht
vor ordentliche gerichte gebracht werden
das ist nicht mehr unsere familie
sepp blatter hat sein versprechen
gehalten
2010 fand die fußball weltmeisterschaft
in afrika statt
graf
dass er die wm 2010 nach südafrika
brachte ist ein historisches verdienst
des wortes kein sportmanager traute sich
zuvor einen internationalen grossanlass
an diesen kontinent zu vergeben zu
problematisch zu unsicher erschien dies
[Musik]
dafür wird sepp blatter in afrika
verehrt auch in den südafrikanischen
townships
danke mister blatter sie sind von gott
gesandt
die wm in südafrika das war sepp
blatters größter triumph
3,4 milliarden franken spielte dieses
turnier in die fifa kasse afrika gewann
an selbstbewusstsein und nun zeigt die
aktuelle untersuchung der us-justiz das
auch bei der vergabe dieser spiele geld
geflossen sein soll zehn millionen
dollar soll korrupten fifa kadern
zugesteckt worden sein und laut new york
times soll blatter intimus jerome valcke
der fifa-generalsekretär diese zahlungen
veranlasst haben
im jahr von südafrikas fußball wm waren
zwei weitere mitglieder des
fifa-exekutivkomitees unter
korruptionsverdacht geraten
die britische sunday times titelt gold
corp woods for sale stimmen zu verkaufen
[Musik]
amos adamu aus nigeria und reynald
temarii aus tahiti
haben bestechungs angebote nicht
zurückgewiesen
[Musik]
journalisten der sunday times
recherchierten verdeckt und gaben sich
als lobbyisten für den wm endrunden
kandidaten usa aus sie finden die
gespräche mit versteckter kamera die
bilder gingen um die welt und sind auf
der homepage der sunday times zu sehen
gemäss diesen aufnahmen war amos adamu
nicht abgeneigt seine stimme zu
verkaufen für neue rasenplätze wie er
sagte
ich wusste nicht ob wir über der
nigerianischen fußball verband gehen
sollten oder direkt über seen
direkt direkt
eine sache die wir wissen möchten werden
sie dann ihre entscheidung zugunsten der
usa fällt
natürlich das wird sich auswirken
nun sollten wir noch darüber sprechen
wie und wann er das geld bezahlen
wir haben uns ja auf 800.000 dollar
geeinigt
unser angebot ist dass wir
400.000 über die nächsten zwei wochen
bezahlen
und die restlichen 400.000 us dollar
nach der abstimmung im dezember also
ungefähr mitte ende dezember
das ist okay für mich
der inhalt temarii forderte geld für
eine fußball akademie
was würde das kosten denken sie
drei millionen new zealand und dann wäre
das einer der gründe für die staaten
zustimmen wenn wir diese unterstützung
von einer privaten firma bekämen wäre
das nützlich für uns
eine korrupte fifa für den fifa kenner
guido ton juni war das damals alles
keine überraschung
keine ws in keiner weismachen nicht
überrascht wenn man der fifa macht
verfolgt der de facto
kritik als korrupte organisation
dargestellt worden von der schweizer
kriegt also da beleidigt man immer mehr
seiten vorherrscht produktion die
schmutzige geschichte und vor allem ihre
publizität verursachten damals sind der
fifa eine große aufregung die interne
ethikkommission wurde einberufen und
fällte ihre urteile reynald temarii muss
5000 franken busse bezahlen und wurde
für ein jahr suspendiert
amos adamu aus bronze betrug zehntausend
franken zudem blieb er für drei jahre
von allen fifa ämtern ausgesperrt das
war vor fünf jahren adamu und temarii
dürfen mittlerweile wieder in fifa
kreisen verkehren
die wahl war entschieden sehr glatter
schien als seine widersacher aus
getrickst zu haben ein weiteres mal
[Applaus]
wenn ich jetzt mal präsident wurde ja
nicht so schlecht sie
draußen ging der kleinkrieg weiter da
waren jene die mit dem neuen alten
präsidenten an neue bessere zeiten
glaubten und
andere die die fifa nun vollends im
sumpf versinken sahen inzwischen ist
klar seitdem die us justiz im
weltfußball mitspielt muss auch sepp
blatter mit einer ungewissen zukunft
rechnen die wahrscheinlichkeit ist so
groß wie nie dass das ganze system
kollabiert nämlich dann wenn jack warner
und jeffrey web vor den us behörden
aussagen um nicht in den knast zu gehen
die treichler aus dem zürcher unterland
fast tönt ihr abgang wie das letzte
geleit für eine vergangene schülern der
ära